can confirm I'm a big fan I like Tesla I
think Elon does good work but yo these
cars they nearly got me killed what
happened they slammed their brakes on
randomly no way randomly dude it is you
were like sort of vaguely driving the
car and then the brakes slammed on
you'll be driving and you'll turn on so
unlike the model 3 you you've you
flicked the stick up twice and then it
changes from cruise control to auto
drive and you activate full self-driving
and then the model S has like a button
you press or something
I'm driving and it's on the highway and
then there's a merger there's an on-ramp
a normal sane human keeps driving the
driver who's merging on knows you have
the right of way and to yield slows down
allowing you to go forward
full self-driving slams its brakes on
which is would cause would cause an
accident I think there was a video of
that that happened in San Francisco yeah
it slammed its brakes on on the on the
bridge and then all these cars piled up
and people got hurt